spartacus declares for president a new
democratic fresh face so fresh so face
proposes an insane tax rate and
republicans pounced i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show well you know
the democrats are having a bad week when
every headline is about how Republicans
are pouncing like a bunch of cats hiding
in the shadows we bounce well there'll
be a lot of pouncing on today's show
because Democrats not good at what they
do also lots of making fun of Cory
Booker coming up because come on man if
I can't make fun of Cory Booker what was
I born to do people will get to all that
in just a second first if you want to
get somebody a great Valentine's Day
gift and you're not gonna go the flowers
rude and you don't want to go the the
sushi at the gas station root not gonna
say that's happened before but we'll
just say that you should be looking at
mrs. field I mean come on for over 40
years mrs. fields has made delicious
treats like their signature chocolate
chip cookies and melt-in-your-mouth
brownies and this Valentine's Day you
can find their best-selling cookie cakes
and other heart themed treats that make
the perfect presents a surprise and
delight your Valentine mrs. Fields I
mean how could you not just want to buy
it when I say the name mrs. Fields their
cookies and sweets are baked and
prepared daily they always arrive fresh
and flavorful ordering is easy they can
ship your gift anywhere across the
United States plus you can now add a
personal touch with a custom message or
photo mrs. fields even offers 100%
customer satisfaction guarantee which is
pretty sweet also has there anyone who
has not been satisfied by mrs. field
like is there is there anybody who's
received that gift have been like you
know I'm not satisfied I'm giving it
back anyone on earth probably not this
Valentine's Day sent a delicious gift no
one can resist right now get 20% off
your order when you go to mrs. fields
calm and enter promo code Shapiro that
is 20% off any gift for Valentine's Day
and mrs. Fields compro McCoach Shapiro
mrs. Fields calm promo code Shapiro go
check it out right I mean that's a great
gift if I got that I'm not saying if my
wife is listening if I got that real
happy mrs. Fields calm promo code
Shapiro all right so I'm very excited
because for a long time I've been eager
to see the Kamala Harris vs. Cory Booker
vs. Elizabeth Warren primary who will be
the most minority candidate I mean
Elizabeth Warren as we all know is
1/1000 24th Native American and Cory
Booker is 1/1000 24th Spartacus as a
recall the senator from
be back during the Cavanaugh hearings
he's such he's such a bag of tools Cory
Booker I mean it's amazing that people
say Cory Booker seriously because
everything he does is so over
traumatized you know isn't I like
senator Ted Cruz I'm friendly with
Senator Ted Cruz the rap on senator Cruz
back in 2016 when he was running is that
everything that he did seemed like it
was over thought by a couple of steps
well if everything that Cruz did seemed
like it was sort of manipulative or over
thought during the 2016 campaign Cory
Booker it's like the guy it's like the
guy writes a script into his head and
then he says you know what this needs
more explosions and then he rewrites the
script in his head and then he does it
live it's amazing so that's why you have
situations like Cory Booker during the
Kavanagh hearing you will recall but
there is a series of documents about
Brett Kavanaugh that were actually
released publicly like the night before
Cory Booker did this Cory Booker then
went out and said I am violating the
rules and I may be banned from this
Senate committee for violating the rules
by releasing these documents which were
released legally yesterday and then he
said and these documents will show that
Brett Kavanaugh is a vicious racist and
the documents no no such thing we said
if ever there was something like an I
have I am Spartacus moment this is my I
am Spartacus moment it which is like
you're reading the stage direction dude
you know read the stage direction like
if you want people to call you Spartacus
that's when you have your press guy call
up a friendly outlet and say you know
what calling Spartacus in the press this
is when you do the Donald Trump as John
Miller routine and you call up and you
say this is definitely not Cory Booker
but if it were Cory Booker he'd be
telling you to write a piece about how
he Spartacus instead he just goes out
fully publicly and it's like this is my
I am Spartacus moment that's Cory Booker
so Cory Booker is now running the faux
sincere campaign and if you fall for
this you are a dolt you're a dolt I mean
I just I gotta say so senator Booker on
Thursday began calling members of
Congress and informing them he is
running for president the least
surprising announcement since Rosie
O'Donnell came out of the closet
and he's quietly making overtures to
members for support according to three
congressional sources that was yesterday
and then within hours he had openly
announced his intentions and here is his
launch video and to say
that this thing is over produced and
staged and ridiculous would be
understatement by omission it's it's
it's incredible it's incredible I'm
gonna describe it for you if you can't
actually see it you should go and see it
you should subscribe to daily wider so
you can see all of the clips that we
play and see my reaction to them but
this video is just wonderful because
basically the theme of the video is Cory
Booker is just a boy from Newark he's a
boy from Newark who made good because
he's overcome racism and homophobia and
sexism and he's not gay by the way and
all these other things he's out he's
overcome everything in life he's stuck
he was a Newark boy who became mayor of
Newark and still lives in Newark now
what's hilarious about this video as you
will see is that his main message is
that he was mayor of Newark and grew up
in Newark and spent his entire life in
Newark and it sucks just as much as when
he was a kid that's the underlying theme
of the video so he spends his whole life
there trying to make things better
supposedly and nothing is better in New
York
and by the way spend some time in Newark
man that is not a place no what no
insult to people who have spent their
time in Newark Newark is not one of
America's most comfortable cities let's
just put it that way and Cory Booker's
tenure there didn't do much to help the
City of Newark it's like when Camilla
Harris talks about her record in
California and those of us in California
are sitting around going what now like
crime rose while you were the AG and you
were the district attorney in San
Francisco which is now a hole so well
done
it's amazing how failing upward in
politics just seems to be endemic like
the worst you do at least on the
Democratic side at least when when Rick
Perry ran for presidents of the United
States he'd been a good governor of
Texas Carla Harris was an awful AG she'd
been an awful senator she was an awful
District Attorney in San Francisco and
now you've got Cory Booker who is a
garbage mayor of New Jersey a garbage
senator from New Jersey and now he's
gonna run for presidents of the United
States being crappy at your job is
almost a prerequisite to becoming
presidents of the United States if you
are a Democrat like what did Barack
Obama do his senator in Illinois that
radically made Chicago better Chicago
way better now than it was like when
Obama got to Chicago not seeing a ton of
evidence that anyway here is Cory
Booker's ridiculous ad a country where
no one is for god no
one is left behind okay pausing for a
second sorry so he so we're gonna stop
and start this he says we can build a
country where no one has left behind
it's a picture of reams of just homeless
people like you've been in government
dude wouldn't been doing about this
problem
anything yeah you got nothing also his
dramatic reading is so great it's so
over here at the Daily wire we have a we
have an execrable host named michael
moles and michael moles is a former
actor and when he act he sometimes tends
to overdo it but that is nothing
compared to cory booker I mean cory
booker is chewing the scenery like he
has a starving man on an on a desert
island he's chewing that scenery it's
just great so continue mr. Booker on the
table where there are good paying jobs
with good benefits in every neighborhood
where our criminal justice system keeps
us safe instead of shuffling more
children into cages and coffins where we
see the faces of our leaders on
television and feel pride mental picture
of em okay so can we pause it there for
a second I'm just wondering at what
point do we actually get the big screen
reveal that this is actually the movie
drumline because because you'll hear
throughout this ad people drumming and
their there's actual video of random
people drumming it's like some some
white chick in her apartment and she's
drumming away and then he's walking
through a high school corridor and
people are drumming away I really I was
hoping that maybe he would break into
song or maybe he just start breakdancing
in the middle of video just for
entertainment value but it's like he
took all of the cliches and he put them
in a cliche nuclear reactor an outcome
it came a cliche nuclear rod that is
radioactive but also extraordinarily
powerful continue I believe we do
together we will channel or comment in
our hand back into our common purpose
together America
we will rise I'm Cory Booker and I'm
running for president of the United
States of America Wow
wow so together we will rise yeah so
much excitement so much fake excitement
it's just it you gotta love it you gotta
love it it's just spectacular and here's
the thing he's gonna crowd that lame
right there's an intersectional lane
that he's trying to run it now what's
funny about Booker is that when Booker
started his entire pitch is that he
actually was the bipartisan Democrat so
we'll recall if you look back at his
career Jim Garrity does this at National
Review that he started by taking on a
democratic machine in Newark and he ran
in Newark on the platform that I'm not a
radical Democrat and first lost and then
he won and his big thing when he was
mayor of Newark was making these big
dramatic announcement so in 2010 he
joined Chris Christie who was then the
Governor of New Jersey with whom he was
very friendly at the time and Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg on The Oprah
Winfrey Show to accept an eye-popping
gift a hundred million dollars to reform
Newark Public Schools with local
philanthropist and others matching it
and raising it to two hundred million
dollars right it was it was a really
good day for a Cory Booker and then
you'll recall that his mayor of Newark
he decided that he was gonna do like the
food stamp test and try to live on on
Supplemental Nutrition Assistance every
day for a month which didn't even make
sense because its Supplemental Nutrition
Assistance it's not supposed to be like
the entirety of your income for the
entire month but then when he went to
the Senate he just decided he was going
to give up being bipartisan at all that
was because there was real backlash to
him in 2012 people were attacking
private equity and Booker fought back
against that Booker said you know why
are we attacking private equity he says
it's getting we're getting to a
ridiculous point in America especially
that I know I live in a state where
pension funds unions and other people
are investing in companies like Bain
Capital if you look at the totality of
bain Capital's record they've done a lot
to support business to grow business and
this to me I'm very uncomfortable with
the last point I'll make is this kind of
stuff is nauseating to me on both sides
it's nauseating to the American public
enough is enough stop attacking private
equity and then the Democrats came down
on him and then he flipped and then he
released a video that completely
reversed himself nope renowned private
equity was absolutely terrible now when
he left as mayor of Newark nothing
actually had happened in Newark right
here is the New York Times
upon him leaving when snow blanketed
this city two Christmases ago Mayor Cory
Booker was celebrated around the nation
for personally shoveling out residents
who had appealed for help on Twitter but
here his administration was scorned as
streets remained impassable for days
because the city had no contract for
snow removal last spring Ellen DeGeneres
presented mr. Booker with a superhero
costume after he rushed into a burning
building to save a neighbor but Newark
had eliminated three fire companies
after the mayor's planned to plug a
budget hole failed in recent days mr.
Booker has made the rounds of the
national media with his pledge to live
on food stamps for a week but his
constituents do not need to be reminded
that six years after the mayor came into
office now and to make Newark a model of
urban transformation their city remains
an emblem of poverty so there he is like
walking around doing his I'm cool New
Works an awesome place thing he didn't
make it an awesome place it continued to
be Newark and again credit to people who
live in Newark the brave are nice but
come on come on Cory Booker is a fraud
he's been a fraud for a long time and he
is just maintaining his fraudulent
status doesn't mean he won't get the the
royal treatment from the media of course
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about a great gift that
you can get for yourself or for a friend
I'm talking about the gift of an awesome
watch at his price that is not going to
break the bank
okay movement watches are just fantastic
I know I own two of them my dad owns one
my mom owns one
my wife owns one like we got them for
everyone in the family because they are
sleek they are minimalist they are
really good looking watches I wear one
every day they're terrific and not only
are they good they are also not wildly
expensive and you know that I'm all
about supporting grounds upon footprints
who work hard from what they want that's
why I love movement watches they're a
true success story
it makes wearing their products that
much more meaningful they made a name
for themselves in one of the most
established markets in the world they've
reached exponential growth it's a really
really great company movement watches
start at just 95 bucks you're looking at
400 to 500 bucks for the same quality at
department stores clean design minimal
they have great quality products
movement has sold almost 2 million
watches in over 160 countries and right
now you get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro cy movement
keeps growing check out their expanding
collection go to MVM t.com slash shapiro
and join the movement again when you use
that slash capiro you get 15% off today
when I say that Cory Booker is a fraud I
mean that in the most literal sense I
mean man is legitimately a fraud
you'll recall that a few years ago there
was a big controversy because he made up
a friend he made up his newark friend
Eliana johnson who's now a reporter for
The Washington Post at the time writing
for National Review talked about this
street character who he'd known who it
turned out was a composite from his life
right here is here is eliana Johnson
writing about this she says the tale is
one Booker admits he's told a million
times according to the Newark
star-ledger Ronald rice jr. a New York
City Councilman and Booker Ally who has
known the mayor since 1998 says the
t-bones story was a fixture of Booker's
unsuccessful 2002 mayoral bid against
corrupt Newark political boss Sharpe
James what exactly was the story t-bone
was a drug pusher that the mayor has
said threatened his life at one turn and
sobbed on his shoulder at the next the
problem is that t-bone does not exist
hey the t-bone tale never set Russ never
sat right with Rutgers University
history professor Clement price a Booker
supporter who told National Review
Online he found the mayor story
offensive because it pandered to a
stereotype of inner-city black men
t-bone Price says is a southern
inflected name you not you would expect
to run into something or someone named
t-bone in Memphis not Newark so t-bone
it turns out is fake and this is not the
first time that Booker has lied about
things but it just shows that the guy is
just a fraud and the media are gonna
treat him as the second coming because
they've always treated him as the second
coming because he does weird quirky
things that the media likes and he's a
vegan and he likes to talk about he gets
manicures all right so he left his city
in shambles he's been a garbage senator
he was this hole he came into the Senate
promising bipartisan cooperation and
then one of his first moves was to
endorse the awful Iran deal over the
objections of a lot of his own Jewish
supporters who were very upset with him
so Cory Booker in the race just another
candidate for you to learn to dislike
very exciting stuff meanwhile the
Democrats continued to promote their
most radical the most radical proposals
and this is also the problem for Cory
Booker Booker's main appeal originally
was that he was a guy who could reach
across the aisle but the Democratic
Party no longer wants to reach across
the aisle they want to push further and
further to the left and this is why
they've endorsed legitimately bad people
like Ilhan Omar the representative from
Minnesota so she had a
couple of viral quotes in the last 48
hours viral quote number one she said
that Israel should not exist she's an
anti-semite
Ilhan omar there there's just no doubt
about this I mean she's associated with
people who are terrorist friendly
she has essentially cause she's now
calling for the abolition of the only
Jewish state on planet Earth
she has suggested that Israel has
deceived the world and may Allah lift
the veil from people's eyes
Ohan omar is a bad lady she's a bad lady
and here is Ilhan omar explaining on
yahoo news that israel really should not
exist if you just stop existing and i
see is what you'll institute law that
recognizes it as a Jewish state and does
not recognize the other religions that
are that are living in it and we still
uphold it as a democracy in the Middle
East
I almost chuckle because I know that if
you know we we say we see that in in any
other society we would criticize that we
would call it out we do that to Iran we
do that to any other place that sort of
upholds its religion she's a crazy
person she's created me what she's
saying here is patently false
it is patently false the reason that we
criticize Iran is not because it is a
state that has Islam as its official
religion the reason that we criticize
Iran is because Iran is a repressive
dictatorship that murderers gay people
in prisons dissidents and prevents
people from freely exercising their
religion Israel doesn't do any of those
things there are many states by the way
in Eastern Europe that have Christianity
as their official religion the idea that
an internal Jewish state law that says
that Judaism is the official state
religion of the Jewish state that this
is in any way controversial in a in a
country where Christians are free to
live work and prosper Muslims are freer
in Israel than they are in any Muslim
country on planet Earth that you can
compare that to Iran ok and this lady is
on the House Foreign Affairs Committee
she's on the House Foreign Affairs
Committee that's where they put her in
the Democrat but they're not radical she
also said Ilhan Omar that Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez is proposal to tax the
super wealthy people who make above what
was it seventy about ten million dollars
a year to tax them at 70 percent she
said that doesn't go far enough here was
her explanation what she thinks the tax
code should be there are a few things
that we can do one of them is that we
could increase the taxes that people are
paying who are the extremely wealthy in
our communities so 70% 80% we've had it
as high as 90% I think what picks up for
a lot of people is taxing the rich up to
80 90 percent or 78 and you know one
percent must pay a fair share okay the
one percent let me explain something one
percents are not people making 10
million dollars or above per year
they're people making about $400,000 per
year as a couple and she's talking about
now taxing them at 90 percent at 90
percent and by the way if you think the
Democrats are gonna stop there you're
totally wrong I mean they they're not
gonna stop there because the truth is
there just isn't enough income from that
group to support any of the programs
they're talking about as I've said
repeatedly on the program if you want
Denmark type socialism you have to have
Denmark type tax rates and that means
60% taxation leaving aside the VAT tax
on people who are making like 60 grand
and above because we're gonna spend even
more than ten mark on these programs
okay so this is just it's just madness
the Democrats have gone completely
radical on all this and that's why Cory
Booker can't run as old Cory Booker he
can't run as the bipartisan guy who is
going to reach across the aisle no one
in his party wants that even his opening
campaign ad which is purportedly about
unity all that's gonna go by the wayside
it's gonna be about who can punch
Republicans more strongly in the mouth
and Democrats now have to engage in this
sort of self delusion where they are
actually moderate it's pretty amazing
it's pretty amazing the leader in self
delusion in the country right now is
Paul Krugman now Paul Krugman won a
Nobel Prize not for economics generally
I mean because economics is an entire
field he won a Nobel Prize for his trade
Theory stuff his trade theory stuff is
quite good Paul Krugman on everything
else the man is a dunce and when it
comes to politics he was particularly
ridiculous
so he has an article today ripping on
Howard Schultz which has become the
stock in trade for the entire left-wing
media Howard Schultz is the bad guy
Howard Schultz is a bad guy because he's
a centrist we don't need centrist right
now here's what Paul Krugman writes
trying to trying to convince himself
almost that Democrats are not in fact
radical he says why is American politics
so dysfunctional
whatever the deeper roots of our
distress the proximate cause is
ideological extremism powerful factions
committed to false views of the world
regardless of the evidence notice that I
said factions plural there's no question
that the most disruptive dangerous
extremists are on the right well I mean
there there is a fair bit of question
about that considering that Democrats
are now talking about overthrowing the
entire American healthcare system
overthrowing the entire American
transportation system and restructuring
the entire American economy if I had to
make a bet I would say those people are
slightly more dangerous than Donald
Trump tweeting stupid crap from the
White House he says but there's another
faction whose obsessions and refusal to
face reality have also done a great deal
of harm but I'm not talking about the
left shocker it turns out that there are
factions that are bad but not the left
the left is not a bad faction radical
leftists are virtually non-existent in
American politics this is Paul Krugman
writing this a radical leftist radical
leftists are virtually non-existent in
American politics can you think of any
prominent figure who wants to move up to
move to the left and say Denmark Denmark
is pretty far left dude in Denmark as I
just mentioned has tax rates that are
unbelievably exorbitant on people who
are lower middle class what are you even
talking about but I guess when you
reshift the entire framework of politics
so that suddenly Denmark becomes
middle-of-the-road all right I mean I
guess it's the thing you can do he says
he's really worried about fanatical
centrists fanatical centrist he says
first there's an obsession with public
debt this obsession might have made some
sense back in 2010 when some feared a
greek-style crisis although even then I
could have told you that such fears were
misplaced in fact I did write you also
said the internet would not be a thing
in the economy Paul Krugman so if we're
gonna go back to your record of
predictions you there's been some good
and there's been some bad he says in any
case however eight years have passed
since Erskine Bowles and Alan Simpson
predicted a fiscal crisis within two
years unless their calls for spending
cuts were heated yet us borrowing costs
remain at historical lows and then he
says that anybody who thinks that that
is a problem is crazy that's crazy it's
not crazy to say that you want a green
nudes you'll do it cost 50 trillion
dollars over 10 years
it is crazy however it is totally crazy
to say that the national debt is a
problem and then he continues along
these lines he says in general centrists
are furiously opposed to any proposal
that would ease the lives of ordinary
Americans universal health coverage said
Schultz would be free health care for
all which the country cannot afford and
he's not alone in saying things like
that a few days ago Michael Bloomberg
declared that extend
Medicare to everyone as Kamala Harris
suggests what bank Ressa bankrupt us for
a very long time now single-payer health
care actually called Medicare hasn't
bankrupted Canada in fact every advanced
country besides America has some form of
universal health coverage and manages to
afford it first of all America does have
a basic form of universal health
coverage it is basically Medicaid it is
Medicaid an emergency room forced care
right so the idea that people are dying
on the streets in America is simply a
left lie it is also true the vast
majority of spending on health care in
the United States is done in the private
sector by people who voluntarily pay
into the private sector the United
States spends something on the order of
60 I believe it was sixty trillion
dollars here so I'll have to look this
up it's sorry it would be sixty trillion
dollars over the next decade that
America could be expected to spend on
health care we have obviously not 60
trillion here 60 trillion over the next
decade that we could be expended
expected to spend on health care about
twenty eight trillion dollars of that
was expected to be public and about
thirty two trillion was expected to be
private okay so that means that a lot of
the spending that's being done is
voluntary spending by people who are
freely alienating their money in return
for quicker health care but according to
Paul Krugman it is not radical at all to
say you're going to completely abolish
one-fourth of the American industry
that's so radical centrists are the real
problem he says where is the fanaticism
of the centrist come from sheer vanity
both pundits and plutocrats like to
imagine themselves as superior beings
standing above the political fray I mean
does Paul Krugman own a mirror somebody
weaned we need a government programs by
Paul Krugman a mirror if we tax
everybody one set we can buy him a
magnificent mirror they want to think of
themselves as standing tall against
against extremism right and left yet the
reality of American politics is
asymmetric polarization extremism on the
right is a powerful political force
while extremism on the left isn't the
answer for centrist is retreating into a
fantasy world
almost as hermetic as the right-wing Fox
News bubble in this fantasy world Social
Democrats like Harris or Warren our
portrayed is the second coming of Google
Chavez so that taking what is actually a
conservative position can be represented
as a brave defense of moderation so now
Howard Schultz is an out-and-out
conservative so in order to defend the
extremism of their own cause Howard
Schultz becomes a conservative in L Han
Omar he comes
pretty amazing stuff but this is how the
media generally have treated the
extremism of the Democrats so what's
hilarious over over the last week is
that we have seen in the last week
Kamala Harris embraced Medicare for all
the abolishing private health insurance
and then runs screaming from it we have
seen Democrats embrace murder of the
unborn up to point of birth including
dilation according to Cathy Tran the
state senator in Virginia the state
delegate in Virginia we have seen
Democrats embrace tax rates that would
make Google Chavez extraordinarily happy
I mean ninety percent on the top one
percent that that's a pretty solid tax
rate right there from Ilhan omar and
company and yet the way that the media
have covered these things is always
Republicans pounced
it's an amazing thing I've never seen I
really have never seen a bevy of
headlines whenever Republicans make a
mistake it's never Democrats pounced as
Republicans as Republicans real it's
never Democrats pouncing
but Republicans pounds has become such a
meme that people on the right know that
as soon as Democrats do something bad
there will be a bevy of articles about
Republicans pouncing so here is an
actual headline from the Washington Post
I can do not is it I'm reading it
straight I'm not making it up okay
quote Republicans seize on liberal
positions to paint Democrats as radical
do you mean we quote them like we play
clips of them like on places like this
show and then we say they're radical cuz
they're like you know radical is by Matt
Weiser senator Kamala Harris is raising
the possibility of eliminating private
health insurance senator Elizabeth
Warren and other prominent Democrats are
floating new and far-reaching plans to
tax the wealthy in Virginia Governor
Ralph Northam voice support for state
legislation that would reduce
restrictions on late term abortions
Democrats after two years largely spent
simply opposing everything president
Trump advocated are defining themselves
lately in ways Republicans are seizing
on to portray them as far outside the
American mainstream
well those Republicans dastardly
Republicans suggesting that these
positions are outside the mainstream
what if there were you don't like some
poll data well I'm willing to assume
maybe the major oil companies and did
polls about these issues and then we
could actually determine whether these
were extreme positions for example oh
wait there are when people are told that
Medicare for all would
their tax is only 26% of Americans
support that when Americans are asked
about whether they would ban on
semi-automatic weapons as Kamala Harris
suggested only 40% of Americans back
that when Americans are asked whether
they support the ability to abort a baby
at dilation 81% of Americans oppose yes
these numbers are available but no it's
Republicans pouncing it's all about the
pouncing Republicans are like the Bobcat
they're just gonna pounce on you that's
a thing I love it that's not the only
one New York Times is doing exactly the
same thing
Trump pens lead GOP seizure of late term
abortion as a potent 2020 issue they
seized it the GOP seized it okay you
know what's a way that the Republicans
couldn't have actually seized on the
issue is if Democrats hadn't tried to
pass bills in Vermont Virginia in New
York and Rhode Island in last week
trying to say that late term abortion
was an affirmative good then there
wouldn't have been anything like let's
say that Republicans tried to seize on
Democratic support for murdering all
people above the age of 80 it would be
hard for them to seize on that because
Democrats haven't actually made that
proposal it'd be hard to seize on it but
whenever a this is the the Andrew Clavin
rule of the media whenever a Democrat
screws something up the story is the
Republican reaction whenever Republicans
screw something up the story is the
Republicans screwing something up but
don't worry that there is no bias in the
media Virginia don't worry no bias in
the media whatsoever
they are just even-handed truth tellers
seeking to be firefighters bringing you
the realities of life by the way it is
worth noting here that for all of the
talk from people like Paul Krugman and
folks in the democratic mainstream about
the realism of their proposals taking
crises like climate change super
seriously and all of this as soon as you
dig beneath the surface you realize that
even their more mainstream positions are
actually pretty radical and pretty dumb
I'll explain in just a second
when it comes to climate change first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and subscribe $9.99 a month
gets you a subscription remember if
you're not a daily wire subscriber you
are missing out our next Sunday special
guest is none other than the great Dave
Ramsey it's a great episode if you are a
subscriber you and only you can watch
this episode a full day early so the
Sunday special
becomes the Saturday special I didn't
film it on Shabbos don't worry my Jewish
fans but only if you are a daily wire
subscriber what are you waiting for it's
time to subscribe
go click subscribe you'll thank me later
but as it look later today because later
today we have another 2 hours of this
show my goodness the amount of content
we bring to you lucky people go check it
out right now
$9.99 a month also annual subscription
$99 here you get this the very greatest
in all beverage vessels cast your eyes
upon it and despair that you own it's
not the leftist here is hot or cold
tumblr it is magnificent if only that
guy at the end of Indiana Jones and the
Holy Grail had chosen this he would
still be alive instead of having
crumbled into dust he chose poorly go
check us out over at Daily wire comment
subscribe also subscribed at YouTube and
iTunes leave us a nice review because
that's the kind of person you are you're
nice just go do that do that right now
I'm waiting okay wait okay now you're
not good great go do that and you know
thanks the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
man I'm glad it's a Friday anyway so
China's coal plants this is this is
great so the Democrats have been saying
that climate change is something we have
to take so seriously we have to hamper
and destroy the entire fiscal stability
of the United States we're voting by the
way that despite all of the talk about
the American economy slowing down
US employers added three hundred four
thousand jobs in January so the the
worries about the economy may be
overstated we'll find out
but Democrats our firmly convinced that
climate change is the most pressing
issue on the agenda this is what all of
the Democrats say if you ask them what
is the existential threat to the United
States they will not say China they will
not say Russia they will not say Islamic
extremism what they will say is climate
change to a person and what they suggest
is that America radically restructure
our economy in a green new deal yay
we're going to abolish you driving of
private cars we are going to cut our
military in half we're going to
radically restructure all of the tax
brackets weird how all of their
solutions to climate change sound
exactly like their ideal fiscal
proposals just in a vacuum
weird how those things line up Wow okay
but there's one problem it turns out
that all of the highfalutin talked about
how the United States has not done its
share it's of to fight climate change
is ignoring the fact that the vast
majority of emissions are not coming
from the United States on an absolute
basis the vast majority of emissions are
coming from China because China has a
billion people and they're emitting
without any regulations upon them
despite the fact that they signed on to
the much-vaunted
Paris Accords remember the Paris Accords
Donald Trump pulled out of it and the
world was supposed to end we were all
going to die well it turns out we didn't
sign the Paris Accords and we lowered
emissions more than any industrialized
country last year and China did sign the
Paris Accords and they didn't lower
emissions at all sameen e Sengupta
writing for the New York Times
China the world's coal juggernaut has
continued to produce more methane
emissions from its coal mines
despite its pledge to curb the planet
warming pollutant according to new
research in a paper published Tuesday in
Nature communications researchers
concluded that China had failed to meet
its own government regulations requiring
coal mines to rapidly reduce methane
emissions at least in the five years
after 2010 when the regulations were
passed it matters because coal is the
world's dirtiest fossil fuel and China
is
by far the largest producer in the world
Kolak ounce for 40% of electriss--
electrical generation globally and an
even higher share in China which has
abundant coal resources and more than 4
million workers employed in the coal
sector scientists and policymakers agree
that the world will have to quit coals
have any hope of averting catastrophic
climate change how quickly China can do
that therefore is crucial the Chinese
government in 2010 required a state-run
coal sector to reduce methane emissions
by putting the gas to use or by
capturing methane from mines and flaring
it which is still polluting but not as
much as releasing the gas into the
atmosphere according to researchers it
required that 6.2 million tons of
methane produced from coal mining be put
to use by 2015 an examination of
satellite data collected between 2010
and 2015 painted a different picture not
only the word the reductions not made
but Chinese methane emissions actually
increased by 1.2 million tons per year
during the five-year period
what a communist dictatorship pledging
to help the environment in order to
shame Western countries into doing the
same and then cheating
you mean communist lie you mean
communist dictatorships that have giant
gulags don't care if they pollute at the
expensive people other places in the
that's crazy
that's good but but there they're good
cuz they're on the Left I mean if we
Thomas Friedman I was I was assured by
Thomas Friedman that if we had just run
America as a one-party autocracy that
would have been even better than one
party democracy because if the one-party
autocracy is run by the geniuses like
the people in China the world would be
better off obviously the solution to
this is we have to tax the 1% the
solution to the Chinese government just
radically increasing their methane
emissions we have to tax some 1% in this
country that is the only way not only
that we should probably have a wealth
tax not only that we should probably
boycott Israel like we sure you know
what we should just do a bunch of things
that have nothing to do with methane
emissions but we will pretend that they
have everything to do with methane
emissions well the other people who
signed on to the Paris Accords and lied
about what they were going to do
continue to pollute clearly that's the
solution this will it's our fault of
course I mean come on or America
it's obviously our fault it's just
amazing that this this continues to be
portrayed as some sort of moderation
just just
just incredible stuff from the
Democratic Party on a routine basis
speaking of incredible stuff from the
Democratic Party remember that time that
everybody said that Donald Trump was a
pawn of the Russians
you remember Hillary Clinton accusing
Donald Trump of being a puppet and Trump
going I'm not the puppet you hear the
puppet Pinocchio
remember that is great well now it turns
out that the United States being a
puppet of Vladimir Putin is withdrawing
from a nuclear arms control treaty
because of ongoing violations by the
Russians
the intermediate-range nuclear forces
treaty has been central to limiting the
kinds of nuclear weapons both countries
can deploy without it experts fear there
will be a new nuclear arms race except
that these experts are doltish enough to
fail to recognize that the Russian
government has been violating the INF 4
legitimately decades
Pompeyo said when an agreement is so
brazenly disregarded and our security so
openly threatened we must respond
Pompeyo first announced the u.s.
intention to withdraw in december giving
russia a 60-day window to come back into
compliance that window runs out on
Saturday
withdrawal now requires an additional
six-month window according to the
treaties terms US officials have also
been concerned about China's growing
military prowess as China is not a party
to the Cold War pact officials worry
that puts the u.s. at a military
disadvantage although the real reason
that they're doing this is because the
Chinese are just because the Russians
are violating the treaty so all of the
puppetry in which apparently Putin is
engaged has resulted in the United
States building up its nuclear arms in
order to counter the violations of the
Russians so amazing so much is so much
puppetry obviously Donald Trump was a
plant of the Russians and he was put in
office by Vladimir Putin specifically so
that he could kill Russians in Syria arm
the Ukrainians with deadly weaponry
raise sanctions for the most part and
also pull out of an intermediate nuclear
forces treaty that allows the United
States to build up its nuclear arsenal
clearly that's why they put them in
power to do stuff like that I mean no
question right I guess we'll still keep
going with this with this Trump is a
puppet to the Russians and sold Trump is
out of office that's that's the plan
because none of this has to do with
anything remotely resembling reality oh
well okay meanwhile let's you know let's
get to the mailbag because it's been a
long week so let's mailbag it up here we
go so
Courtney says dear Ben today is my 25th
birthday so I wanted to ask you what was
the best thing that happens to you when
you were 25 and what advice would you
give your 25 year old self or just some
advice for 25 year olds in today's world
sincerely one of your biggest fans when
I was 25 I was newly married so I got
married when I was 24 and my wife was 20
or about three and a half years apart if
you do that math and when you're 25
honestly I think this is it's a rule
anytime you're young what makes you a
better person is taking on more
responsibilities not shirking
responsibility taking on the burdens of
responsibility for another human being
makes you stronger it makes you better
it makes you have to engage with your
best self getting married was a
life-changing experience for me in a
variety of ways but the first thing that
it does is it makes you realize that
your decisions have impact on people who
are not you and you're just a kid you
don't worry about the impact that your
decisions have on your parents now that
you're now that I'm a parent you realize
how much parents have to deal with the
consequences of their children's
decision but when you're a kid you think
oh my parents an adult my parent can
handle it they're older that once you
get married you realize that your
decisions don't just impact you they
impact others and this makes you a more
virtuous person so when you're 25 my
first suggestion is seek responsibility
don't shirk responsibility that would be
I think the first thing that pops to
mind the other thing is that you should
when you're young you should be risk
seeking when it comes to career what I
mean by that is it now is a good time
for you to try and determine what it is
that you love to do you think makes a
difference and that you're good at right
that is the confluence of factors that
make for a good career experience find
the thing that you are good at the thing
that you love to do and the thing that
other people will pay you to do and
makes a difference right though those so
making a difference good at it people
will pay you for it those are those are
the three things when I was 25 I'd been
working at a law firm and I worked there
for about ten months it was you know not
a great experience I didn't love it it
was a major law firm it was during the
middle of the real estate downturn it
was a real estate contract law firm it
was a transactional law firm so I was
sitting in my beautiful office and
Century City looking out at the ocean
every day for like seven hours a day
well I couldn't bill any hours because
there was no work coming in I just
biased it I hated it and I was making a
really good salary doing it and I
decided you know what I'm newly married
we're still young we can afford a little
bit of a hit so if I'm
we're gonna change career paths now's
the time to do it so I quit after 10
months I had a mortgage I had a wife and
we decided that I was going to take a
job for 1/3 to pay doing legal work and
also learning the production side of the
radio industry because this is a good
time for you to learn it's a good time
for you to jump and I did that it
changed my career path entirely I mean I
maybe I'd be a partner at a law firm
right now if I had not done that but I'm
much happier with what I'm doing now so
25 is a great age Harrison says hi Ben
milton freedman commonly referred to
inflation has the hidden tax because it
pushes people's income into higher and
higher tax brackets he concluded that
the only way to effectively get a tax
cut is to cut government spending
because any tax cut that did not cut
spending would ultimately lead to
inflation so you agree with this
analysis and you think Republicans will
ever tackle government spending thank
you so yes I agree with Milton
Friedman's analysis I think that that is
correct I think that if you continue to
spend then eventually you're going to
have to increase taxes or you're gonna
have to inflate the currency to pay off
the debt that you have incurred in order
to make that spending happen so that of
course is true so I think Republicans
will ever tackle government spending I
think that everyone is going to have to
tackle government spending when the
rubber meets the road I mean even the
Europeans have had to tackle government
spending because at a certain point
austerity measures are necessary
he can't indefinitely pay bills with
other people's money families has been
could you provide some recommended
reading on intersectionality and where
it came from
and why it's become so popular I sure
could I have a new book with an entire
section on intersectionality and go
check it out at Amazon or at Barnes and
Noble the right side of history that is
coming out in March I have sort of a
long explanation of the roots of
intersectionality you can also read the
papers of kimberlé crenshaw who's the
person who came up with
intersectionality so a couple things
about intersectionality a friend of mine
recently sent me a paper by kimberlé
crenshaw
about intersectionality in a legal
journal and the paper isn't actually bad
right what the paper actually suggests
and this is true is that if you are
going to take into account
discrimination based on a variety of
factors there are cases in which factors
stack up on top of one another so for
example there could be a case in this
paper by kimberlé crenshaw she
specifically talked she's the person who
founded the the phrase intercept the the
term intersectionality in the paper she
talks about a case where a black woman
was discriminated on the basis of both
her race and her sex but because there
was no law that said that the aggregate
of those two factors was
could could be a protected class
therefore she was left out of the law
okay that's a fair argument I can see a
situation in which a black woman is
treated as lesser than a white woman so
in other words she's treated lesser than
a man because she's a woman but also
treated a lesser than a white woman
because she's black right you could see
that sort of hierarchy in a
discriminatory setting the problem is
that drawing the broad conclusion that
simply by membership in a group you are
therefore victimized by necessity and
it's not a baseline assumption it's that
we will ignore your personal experience
and simply dictate that America is bad
to people like you without reference to
what you have done personally that is in
essence a form of racism so there
there's a great new book out by noah
rothman i recommended it earlier this
week it's called unjust I was all about
social justice and he has a long
explanation of intersectionality I would
check that out as well
but I was making this point to somebody
yesterday about intersectionality and
the real problem with it again the idea
of intersectionality is that we're all
members of groups and these groups have
been treated desperately in American
history which is obviously true but that
does not answer the question of what
that means for us now should we look to
your personal experience and your
personal experience of discrimination or
should we simply assume that your
membership in the group means that you
have been discriminated against in some
way and therefore your opinion should be
valued more highly when it comes to
critiquing the United States and our
hierarchies of power it's that latter
contention that is actually racist
identity politics that latter contention
is racist identity politics Thomas
Sowell The Economist has an interesting
breakdown of discrimination that I found
quite useful he says that there are
basically three types of discrimination
there's discrimination that we all find
utterly benign that would be
discrimination between do I want a
hamburger or but I want a fish fillet
today right that we discriminate with if
you have discriminating tastes this does
not mean you are a bad person it means
that you made a choice right that's the
kind of discrimination that no one cares
about then there is open discrimination
there's there's you're a black person
therefore you're lesser that is racism
that is discrimination
everybody finds that important of good
of good faith then there's the case of
situation there are situations in which
you have no information about a person
other than their group membership so for
example you're walking down the street
of a neighborhood in that neighborhood
the black crime rate
higher than the white crime rate and
you're walking down the street at 2:00
a.m. and you're walking down the street
and they're identical and identically
dressed black eye on one side of the
street and white guy on the other side
of the street and you cross over to the
side where the white guy is because the
black crime rate in the city is higher
than the white crime rate are you a
racist
Thomas Oil says no what you are is a
person who is using risk assessment
based on the only data in that is
available to you racism would be if you
know that the one that the black guy
walking down the street is dressed in a
medical outfit because he's from Johns
Hopkins and the white guy on the other
side of the street is smoking crack if
you then move over to the white guy's
side of the street then you're a racist
in other words you can only use the best
data that is available to you and our
job should be to try and drill down so
we get to the individual data well
intersectionality is the same sort of
problem ok so if you were to say that in
a vacuum all you have in about
information about these two people one
is white and one is black you don't know
anything else about them can you say
that they probably had different
experiences in America yeah I think it's
fair to say that they probably had
different experiences in America because
being black comes with certain burdens
that being white has not had
historically speaking we could probably
assume for example without any other
evidence that you have a history of less
wealth in your family because of
historic discrimination against black
folks uncontroversial here's where
intersectionality goes wrong
intersectionality suggests that even if
you know now that that black kid is
Colin Powell's son and you know that
that white kid is some kid who grew up
in rural Appalachia with a single mom
you can still assume that that white kid
is somehow privileged by his race and
that black kid is somehow a victim
because of his race now you are actively
encouraging discrimination and that's
where intersectionality has gone and
it's ugly and it's gross and once you
start using group identity as a
substitute for in for information that
you have about individual
decision-making once you say that every
disparity can automatically be
attributed to discrimination because
discrimination is obviously so endemic
that it overcomes any other factor now
you have engaged in something truly ugly
you're seeing this right now with Howard
Schultz Howard Schultz grew up Jewish in
a family where his father apparently
beat him and was a truck driver and was
unemployed they were on welfare they
were they were living in public housing
he made something of himself and he
became the head of an 84 billion dollar
corporation that he started from a
coffee shop in Seattle amazing American
success story
he is now being accused of having
experienced white privilege and even
Jewish privilege because his culture
emphasizes education for example so we
are going to value his group identity
over his individual story that's the
essence of racism it is it's the absent
the essence of the bad kind of
discrimination Thomas Sowell
talks about already a couple more
questions ELISA is dear bettan wanted to
know your opinion on mediums I used to
think all psychics are frauds but one of
my mom's friends who's a medium said my
dad who died 10 years before when I was
14 wanted to speak to me I've rarely
talked to her before and at the time I
was going through a really rough time in
college with heavy drinking depression
and losing out on a girl I had feelings
for and somehow she knew everything
happening even though I told no one at
the time and that changed my opinion on
the subject curious to know what your
thoughts are so my thoughts are that I
think all psychics are frauds
that I think there's no hard data to
suggest that psychics are not frauds I
think that they tend to use the outside
indicators or say vague things that you
can fit into what you think your story
is they'll say you're having trouble
with a romantic partner are you could
that MEF it's like 90% of people they're
like oh my god how they know that how
they know that I'm having trouble with
my romantic partner that I have
unrequited love okay easy guess you
don't have a wedding ring on your finger
so unrequited love and you are unhappy
which is probably why you're there right
they can they can use pretty good
outside indicators they're good at this
I think psychics are frauds because
again I have no evidence to the contrary
Rick says hey Ben the other day you said
that Switzerland has the best health
care system right now after looking over
the particulars it looks a lot like
Obama care because of the mandate and
some subsidies this is correct it does
look a lot like Obama care why do you
like that system since it resembles
Obamacare you've also said that for the
u.s. to allow the purchase of health
insurance over state lines but a plant
in Montana won't pay the rate the
doctors in LA or New York charge your
thoughts well you want to be able to
have competition across state lines and
you're right that a health care plan in
Montana is probably not going to be
something that people in California buy
but a health care plan in South Dakota
might be something that people in
Montana won by the prices differentially
I might want to buy a New York health
plan to cover people in California you
should be able to have competition
across state lines as far as Switzerland
looking a lot like Obamacare that's
correct okay the idea of the individual
mandate itself I find to be a
violation of basic principles of Liberty
I don't think that the government should
be able to force me to buy something
that is for my own care when you buy car
insurance it's to protect the other guy
on the road when you buy health
insurance is to protect you it's not the
government's role to tell me what I have
to purchase for my own good I find that
to be tyrannical what I've said that
intermit I have said is that in terms of
efficacy in terms of efficacy if at all
that's that's all you're looking at
Switzerland has a pretty nice system
okay
Switzerland core principles and also I'm
saying if you're looking at mixed
systems nobody's actually ever tried up
a pretty libertarian system in which the
free market tends to predominate
regulations are extraordinarily low and
people can buy health care simply by
walking into the doctor and plum and
pocking plucking putting down plopping
down and 100 dollar bill okay one more
and then we will move on let's see Stan
says how you doing Ben I know that you
and your wife are happily married but
hypothetically if she were to be
unfaithful to you how would you handle
the situation is adultery a legit reason
to divorce someone I know in the Bible
it says till death do us part but I
think cheating is a horrible act even if
the person did it once I would love to
hear your thoughts on this thanks and
happy belated birthday
so you know I this is a complex topic
actually so on a sin level obviously
adultery is not only divorce about if
you're gonna do biblically its death
penalty worthy right and the the it is
one of the Ten Commandments thou shalt
not commit adultery and it is indeed
grounds for divorce in Judaism what
would I do if god forbid my wife did
that thankfully this is not even a
thinkable hypothetical but if I were
married to somebody who cheated on me
and I already had kids honestly I I
think I would probably do my best to
keep the marriage together for the sake
of the kids so long as she was told
their mother because after you have kids
the math changes if I were just married
to a woman no kids and she cheated on me
I'm not like that if I have kids that
does change the math pretty radically
you have to do something to make sure
that the kids still have their mom
around if she's a good mom if she's a
bad mom then it's a different story but
divorce has impact on people beyond you
this goes back to sort of the first
question in the mailbag as you have
responsibilities to other people the
incentive structure changes and the math
changes I will also say that not all
adulteries are equally damaging to a
marriage I think is is somewhat fair to
say meaning that I think that all
adultery is evil I think it's a great
cruelty I think it's
it's a diminishment of your soul and it
is a violation of your responsibilities
as a human being it creates a breach in
human virtue that is nearly irreparable
I will say that I think there is a
difference between a man having a
long-standing affair with a woman not
his wife and a man who has a drunken
one-night fling at a hotel in Iowa I
don't think that's quite the same thing
and I think that's true because men
treat sex as a disposable thing and
emotional Affairs can be a lot more
damaging to marriages than even
one-night stands for example but that's
getting more complex than topic requires
again it depends on where you're
situated it depends on your relationship
with your spouse so that that's sort of
the basic answer all right time for a
thing I like and then a couple of things
that I hate so things I like today
Ashton Kutcher posted a powerful
pro-life video I don't know that Ashton
Kutcher is pro-life but this video
certainly is pro-life
it's testimony of a man with Down
syndrome he was testifying in front of
Congress and he talked about how eugenic
murder of the unborn is extraordinarily
dangerous here was a little bit of that
video posted by Ashton Kutcher good for
him I am a man what Down syndrome and my
life is worth living
sadly across the world
an ocean is being sold that maybe we
don't need research concerning down to
concerning Down syndrome some people say
we need oh screens will I just I justify
Down syndrome in the womb and those
pregnancies will just be terminated
it's hard for me to sit here and say
those words I completely I completely
understand that the people pushing this
particular final solution are saying
that that people like me should not
exist of course this is true and the
fact is that one of the chief reasons
that people say that abortion ought to
be legal is to dispose of people with
Down syndrome this is one of the things
people will say they'll say what if the
baby is disabled what if the baby is
disabled is this guy's life not worth
living is he worth less than a person
who is fully abled the same folks who
will go crazy in social justice fashion
if you use phrases like tone deaf I'm
not kidding there was a social justice
warrior online today who used the phrase
tone deaf and then she apologized
because she felt that it might offend
people who are deaf I wonder what her
position is on choosing abortion for a
kid who would be born with Down syndrome
or with some other sort of disability
the utter disdain that so many folks on
the pro-choice Left have for people who
are disabled as long as they're in the
womb is pretty astonishing okay time for
a couple of things that I hate so I
think I'm actually gonna do only one
thing I hate so I discuss this yesterday
on my on my radio show and if you
subscribe to the last two hours of the
show you'd already know this you'd
already knows but if you didn't I'm
willing to explain it again Alexandra
Ocasio chorus has said something
completely insane yesterday she's
talking about the so-called Paycheck
Fairness Act which bars employers would
bar employers from asking potential
employees what they were paid at their
last job now listen if you go in for an
interview you don't have to tell your
employer that right if the potential
employer says what were you paying you
say listen I want to negotiate not on
the basis of what I was last paid but
and what I think I'm worth to you you
can still do that everyone has the
ability to do that it's a free country
she wants to bar people from asking that
question are we also not supposed to ask
him ployment history are we supposed to
not ask for recommendations like what
are we not supposed to ask about that
wasn't the dumbest thing Ocasio courts
have said the dumbest thing she said was
this I'm so happy that the Paycheck
Fairness Act addresses among many things
two very critical ones one is that we
cannot ask for salary history and pay
Pete
depending on their salary history any
more that we pay people what they are
worth and not how little they are
desperate enough to accept that last
comment that's absolutely insane when
she says it's time to pay people what
they are worth and not what they are
willing to accept
read a book read a book okay like or go
to the grocery store who decides what
something is worth what are you worth
what is it what is this pen worth what
is this cup worth okay it's worth
whatever you're willing to pay for it
that's how markets work and the way that
we determine what we things think ought
to be what we think things ought to be
worth is we look at the aggregate of
information that amounts to a price a
price is simply an aggregate number that
is put on how much demand there is for
particular products and how much supply
there is of that particular product so
if it's very difficult to produce a
product and so there are only three of
them and there's high demand for it the
prices will be very high if it's very
easy to produce a product and there's
very little demand for it you can
produce a million of them but they're
only three people who wants it the price
will be extraordinarily low close to
free think all of that makes perfect
sense what you can't have is people who
sit at the top of the pyramid who go you
know what I think that that first
product that there are only three of its
really important so the real price of it
should be super cheap yeah I don't care
what you think the price should be that
is not a reflection of reality I think
that pigs should be able to fly that
would be great I don't know why but it
seems like it could be fun and that
doesn't make any sense it doesn't matter
what you think things should be the
Soviet Union tried this they tried to
literally control the price of every
single element of Soviet society and it
turns out that was a giant fail because
there's no way to centralize knowledge
that is greater than the knowledge of
the entire of the entirety of the human
race has to their own interests
aspirations and desires for products
goods and services it is a fundamental
rejection of free markets to suggest
that you know what the proper price of a
things should be better than the market
knows in fact you know better than the
person who's accepting the wage this is
why when people on the Left say well
there should be a $15 minimum wage it's
like okay well you're pulling that
directly from your colon I'm wondering
why you think there should be a $15
minimum wage for which job and as
opposed to what they say well it should
be more than 725 how do you know are you
the person accepting 27 25
are you the person paying the 725 do you
even know those people what are you even
talking about what people tend to do is
they tend to do this it's an actual
psychological phenomenon where they root
into a price that already exists and
then they pretend they know better than
that price so they will say you know box
of Cheerios it turns out cause 479 at a
California Ralph's but it shouldn't cost
479 it should cost three bucks now what
they're doing there is they're saying it
seems like 479 is too expensive so it
would be better if it cost $3 but what
if the actual price of the box of
Cheerios was $50 then they would say
well it seems too expensive I think the
price of a box of Cheerios should be $40
because they're just hooking into the
information they have and then
discounting it based on some vague sense
of unease it doesn't work that way
prices are a reflection of the aggregate
knowledge of the human race your
perception of what a price should be is
a sum of the aggregates stupidity of you
that's it but aoc thinks that should
dictate if you think a OC whose great
life experience consists of winning a
mildly contested primary in New York
City and also having poor drinks if you
think that she knows more than the
entire human race about the price of
goods services wages and labor then I'm
not to tell you go live an ALC land man
because that place will be bankrupt so
fast it'll make your head swim
there will be no production of products
there will be no Goods there'll be no
services there will be a bunch of people
who think that life is fair while they
sit and play in the mud that's basically
what you will have because that's what
the USSR ended up being all right well
as you can see I'm I'm dying here so
we're gonna leave and I'll be back here
a little bit later after I have
sufficiently recovered after I've gone
and had a nice swig from the leftist
tours hot or cold tumblr and have been
reinfield then I will be back for two
live hours later this is why you should
subscribe go check it out if not we will
see her Monday have a wonderful weekend
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19